The SCP Foundation has encountered its fair
share of incredibly tough adversaries and
fearsome monsters, but none are as formidable
- or at least, as durable - as SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile.
We’ve talked about this behemoth before
in a number of mind-boggling videos, and all
of the increasingly desperate lengths the
Foundation has gone to in order to terminate
it.
We’ve gotten so desperate to put this thing
to rest that we’ve even reached out to all
of you for suggestions on the matter.
Sadly, they’ve thrown 682 together with
some of the most destructive anomalies in
Foundation custody, and it’s slithered out
of seemingly inescapable danger every time.
So much so that we’ve noticed certain researchers
on the 682 case have started drinking a little
more heavily as of late…
Sometimes the threats didn’t leave so much
as a dent in the monster’s scales, sometimes
the other creature ran screaming at the sight
of it, and sometimes 682 mutated and twisted
its form in ways that were shocking even to
a Foundation research team that has seen just
about all there is to see.
After all, 682’s truly insane adaptability
has always been its number one power, and
the key to its infuriating death-defying abilities.
And these are some of SCP-682’s craziest
mutations.
During one round of tests, SCP-682 was released
into an enclosure with SCP-272, a nail that
traps any living thing in place when it is
dropped onto the organism’s shadow.
682 was surrounded by 30 two-thousand-watt
stadium lights, one of which was switched
on.
As soon as it entered the enclosure, a D-Class
dropped the nail onto the creature’s shadow.
It was promptly pinned in place, and all thirty
lights were switched on and off in random
patterns, causing the reptile to be hurled
around the room at devastating speeds.
After nearly an hour of this, about 95 percent
of the monster’s skin had been worn down,
sixty-three of its teeth had been broken from
its jaw, and its eyeballs had come loose from
their sockets.
At this point, something truly bizarre happened.
The exposed tissue beneath 682’s top layer
of skin, previously bloody and dark red, began
to give off a bright white light.
The subdermal tissue grew steadily brighter
and brighter until it eclipsed the glow from
the stadium lights, and removed any shadows
cast along the floor.
It collapsed on the ground and continued giving
off violently bright light for the next forty-eight
hours, so bright that it caused permanent
retinal damage to all personnel in the room.
Hell of a light show, but this next mutation
proves just how hard it is to lick SCP-682
- Especially when it develops the tools to
start licking back.
SCP-743 is a chocolate fountain that exhibits
some carnivorous qualities.
When it is near a living organism, especially
if it consumes the fountain’s delicious
chocolate, it produces swarms of ant-like
monsters that devour the organism piece by
piece, carrying the bits into the fountain
until nothing is left.
The research team was curious about the possibilities
of introducing 743 to 682, so it was transported
to the reptile’s testing chamber.
Within a few minutes, chocolate began to flow
from the fountain.
682 was curious and began to drink from it.
It may hate almost everything, but even 682
can’t resist chocolate.
It drank greedily, for several minutes, until
the fountain began releasing the ants.
Within moments, 682 was covered in ants and,
in spite of its best efforts to fight off
the swarm, it was completely covered and rendered
immobile.
The ants made quick work of the massive creature,
and after several minutes it had been stripped
down to less than 80 percent of its original
mass.
It seemed as if this might truly be it for
the beast, but then…it opened its mouth.
It unfurled its tongue, now over 5 meters
long and sticky, comparable to an enlarged
version of an anteater’s tongue.
It began lapping up the ants, thousands at
a time picked up by its mutated tongue.
As it devoured the ants, more poured out of
the fountain, slicing off pieces of 682’S
flesh with their pincers and carrying them
back to the fountain.
They reached a symbiotic pace, feeding on
each other in equal measure for hours until
testing was terminated.
That was a sticky situation.
But trust me, this next crazy mutation will
really blow you away.
SCP-3108, also known as “the Nerfing gun,”
is an altered toy gun that turns anything
it hits into an inferior version of itself.
When the gun was fired at a tissue sample
taken from SCP-682, the sample turned into
a piece of tissue from a giant leaf-tailed
gecko.
Hoping to carry this over and turn 682 into
a harmless animal, a D-class officer was sent
into the containment chamber to fire the gun
at the entity.
Once it was hit with the foam dart, it began
to transform.
Unfortunately, instead of becoming a simple
gecko, it began to mutate.
It grew larger, its muscles bulging noticeably
beneath its scaly skin.
Its teeth grew longer, sharper, its tongue
sprouting teeth of its own.
It opened its mouth to roar, and it appeared
that the teeth, long curved fangs with a deadly
tip, went all the way back down the beast’s
throat.
Security officers were deployed to temporarily
neutralize the monster, but found that it
was even more powerful than before.
Not only was it bigger, but it had developed
a new ability.
When threatened, it would begin to vibrate
at a high rate, grinding its teeth together,
and it would explode in a burst of fire and
meaty chunks.
Fangs flew in every direction like shrapnel,
tearing into personnel and lodging in their
skin.
This is an impressive move, but it seems like
a one-time trick, right?
Wrong.
The bits and pieces, no matter how tiny or
how flattened to mush, would crawl back together
and form the creature all over again.
It was able to escape containment like this,
killing an untold number of personnel before
it was temporarily incapacitated and returned
to its containment.
Mutating back into life from a self-induced
explosion is pretty crazy, but surely you
can’t mutate back from nothing at all, right?
Right!?
Oh boy, I don’t like that look you’re
giving me…
SCP-3930 is a void located near Usinsk, Russia,
within which nothing exists.
Once something has passed within its border,
it ceases to be, though outside observers
will be able to perceive them for a small
time after.
SCP-682 was brought to 3930, and it walked
inside.
Once there, it ceased existing.
However, even though 682 no longer existed,
Foundation personnel looking at the void could
still see the beast.
Whenever they viewed it, a strong image appeared
in the brain of the person looking, and it
had the exact appearance of SCP-682.
Somehow, even when it didn’t exist, 682
was able to attack and kill various personnel.
These people did not die from physical damage,
but from their brain function suddenly, inexplicably
stopping.
The reptile defied the rules of the void,
somehow causing real destruction even though
it was not real.
Fifteen hours later, 682 was found in its
containment chamber as if nothing had happened
at all.
It had been snuffed out of existence and had
mutated its way back into reality, with no
explanation.
Well, that was existentially terrifying.
Thank 343 that at least there’s only one
of these things.
Oh no…
SCP-3207 is a highly efficient mobile war
machine, outfitted with cannons capable of
firing blasts that can vaporize organic matter
on contact.
This seems like a good match for something
supposedly indestructible. 3207 was fired
at 682 several times, appearing to destroy
it completely except for a smudge on the floor
of the chamber.
The reptile was gone for a duration of six
hours before something strange began to happen.
Globs of tissue began to clump together, forming
five separate piles.
They pulled closer and closer together, compressing
into five reptilian creatures.
They writhed around, getting used to their
new legs and teeth, snapping their jaws at
any living thing in sight.
Overwhelming and surprising the security personnel,
who had been lulled into a false sense of
security by the apparent defeat of 682, the
five smaller versions of the entity were able
to escape containment.
Once they had made it into the hallway, they
began to clamber over each other, their scales
shifting, eyeballs squeezing together and
fusing into one eye, skin stretching like
hot rubber over unnaturally bendy bone.
As the shocked security personnel watched,
the five lizards melted into one, becoming
a full-sized version of SCP-682 that was good
as new.
They were able to contain it after a great
deal of effort, but one of the researchers
requested a note be added to the research
notes for the day, and applied going forward:
DO NOT EXPLODE.
Okay, so the big lizard is a constant threat.
Got it.
Still, wouldn’t it be nice if 682 could
make itself a little smaller?
I can’t imagine anything bad coming from
that…
SCP-1056 is an anomalous kitchen timer capable
of changing the size of living objects.
The Foundation wanted to see how long it would
take 682 to return to its original size after
being shrunk.
So, they built a testing chamber connected
to 1056’s dial, and released 682 inside,
sealing the door behind it.
The dial was set to 0.25, and the activation
button was pressed.
682 thrashed around, bellowing as parts of
its body expanded and contracted at random.
Then, with no warning, it disappeared.
D-class personnel were deployed to investigate
the chamber, but it seemed to be completely
gone.
There was no sign of it.
It’s pretty hard to lose a giant lizard,
so naturally, they were all a bit perplexed.
The chamber was kept sealed, under the assumption
that 682 had to still be inside somewhere.
Sometime later, a security officer spotted
682 outside of Site-19, returned to its original
size.
Somehow, during the test, 682 used the effects
of 1056 to strengthen its ability to change
its own size.
It adapted and shrank to a size so small that
no one watching could even see it anymore,
and it slipped out through the sealed door.
It was even temporarily able to change the
size of other objects around it, shrinking
weapons used to contain down until they were
useless.
Okay, so SCP-682 is pretty cool under pressure.
But what if we made it a whole lot colder?
Most of the testing on 682 is done with other
anomalies, however, sometimes the Foundation
likes to simplify a bit.
Dr. Carlson suggested they try something a
bit more basic: liquid nitrogen.
One ton of liquid nitrogen was poured onto
SCP-682 from above.
As it tends to do, the liquid nitrogen promptly
froze the beast solid.
It remained stuck in place for about 10 minutes,
until it began to melt the frozen cast around
it.
Its core body temperature seemed to skyrocket,
producing intense heat that fully thawed it
in three minutes.
It didn’t stop there, though.
Its temperature continued to increase, growing
hotter and hotter as if to deliberately punish
the research staff for even attempting to
freeze it.
It became so hot that the research staff had
to leave the room.
An attending doctor’s pen melted, the plastic
burning his hands.
Steam rose off the sides of its body, fogging
up the windows of the room.
The test was abandoned after the sides of
the containment chamber began to melt, and
they worried the creature would be able to
breach containment.
Once it was left alone, 682 cooled back down
to its usual temperature.
Maybe we should see what happens if we try
a slightly greener method of destruction…
682 was exposed to SCP-166, a young nature
spirit that can cause organic matter in her
vicinity to decompose.
As soon as 166 was released into its chamber,
682 began to run toward her even as its body
began to melt.
As it got closer, it began to decay and fall
apart more rapidly, pieces of its body softening
and sloughing off in chunks.
By the time it reached 166, it had melted
down into the shape of a patch of grass covered
with colorful wildflowers.
Fifteen minutes later, it began to regenerate
itself as it usually does, its body reconstituting
at the same rate it was melting.
The regeneration process began to speed up,
going faster and faster until it surpassed
the rate of melting.
A piece of the monster would soften and flop
to the ground, but by the time it landed a
patch of regrowth had already replaced it.
It eventually beat the melting process and
regenerated to its original form, with one
difference: it had a sprinkling of flowers
and mushrooms on its back, resembling a forest
clearing.
It was almost pretty, even on top of such
a foul creature, until a full-sized tree suddenly
burst out of its back, shooting up to a height
of ten feet and puncturing the roof of its
containment chamber.
And I’m afraid that’s all the time we
have for one video, but this only just scratches
the surface of the weird and wild mutations
we’ve come to expect from SCP-682.
Want another video on even more crazy mutations
from the Hard to Destroy Reptile?
Make your feelings known down in the comments.
Now go check out “How to Kill SCP-682 - Theories
and Ideas” and “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” for
more about the Foundation’s face-offs with
this seemingly indestructible beast!